cyberpunk 2077 is a huge
game with a whole lot of freedom to
approach things however you want
with that in mind here are some good
tips to help you get the most out of
your time
in night city remember to like and
subscribe for more cyberpunk
let's go samurai as you level up you
will get
attribute points and skill points and
while it's fun to learn new skills
attribute points are crucial as they
dictate these base stats and the perks
available to them in that attributes
skill trees upgrading your body will
improve your health
cool improves stealth and reflexes
improve your damage
output with firearms on top of this some
open up different dialogue options while
others give you the strength
to pry open doors attached to each stat
are two to three skill trees which
consist of both active skills and
passive perks
it's good practice to focus on the
attributes that have skills and perks
you're interested in so if you want to
be an efficient netrunner
invest your attribute points into
intelligence that being said you could
save your attributes for when you come
across a door that might require
one more point in body than you
currently have and be a bit more
opportune with your upgrades
these phone is constantly blowing up and
it's in your best interest
to check it regularly most of the time
it'll be a fixer sending you details on
a job or a sick set of wheels that you
can buy
however sometimes the friends you've
made in night city will drop you a line
and you definitely should reply
don't leave them on red because not only
will these messages open up new quests
sometimes
they're just really funny and endearing
speaking of v's phone
there are an overwhelming amount of side
quests in cyberpunk 2077
trying to do all of them on a first
playthrough is ambitious to say the
least
so to take the pressure off of it i
would encourage everyone to help out the
key characters you meet along the way
in my experience these are some of the
best missions and net you some of the
most valuable rewards in the game
you will constantly cycle through new
weapons rather than just tossing your
outdated firearm on the ground you
should sell it
or break it down for components early on
guns are probably the most valuable
things you'll commonly find
the downside is that they weigh a lot
and you have a weight limit on what you
can carry
so i'd recommend selling your old
weapons every chance you get
alternatively you can break down weapons
which will net you some weapon
components that can be used to upgrade
the ones you like
or craft rare weapons but wait
don't break down or sell those iconic
weapons even if you're way over leveled
for them
iconic weapons usually have a perk that
make them unique
so if you find yourself attached to a
specific one
consider upgrading the weapon to keep it
viable instead
this is pretty easy to do when you find
an iconic weapon
you'll automatically get the blueprints
to upgrade it the amount of times you
can upgrade an iconic weapon
depends on the rarity tier you find it
at using common
uncommon rare epic and legendary
components you can upgrade your iconic
weapons in the crafting menu
and keep them around for longer if
you're playing as a netrunner or hacker
you won't be able to do much with the
cyber deck that you start with
cyber decks determine how much ram you
have and allow you to equip
quick hacks the nicer the cyber deck you
have the more quick hacks you have at
your disposal and the more ram you have
the more quick hacks you can do in
succession
so upgrade that puppy asap another quick
tip for netrunners is to
always have a stock of powerful quick
hacks swing by netrunner stores to pick
up new and more powerful quick hacks
which you can slot into your cyber deck
quick hacks are a net runner's bread and
butter these range from abilities that
shred an
enemy's neural system to hacks that jam
an enemy's gun
whether you decide to play as a lethal
or non-lethal netrunner buying and
equipping the right quick hacks
is crucial this should go without saying
but save often
chances are encounters won't always go
as you hoped and you'll want to take
another shot at it
the auto save function is pretty
generous but occasionally i found myself
rolling a little further back than i
would have liked
also the game is pretty buggy right now
sometimes quests will break and the game
might crash
the more you save the less progress you
could lose
so there are 9 tips to help you get the
most out of your early hours in
cyberpunk 2077 if you like this video
give us a thumbs up and subscribe
we've got plenty more on cyberpunk
coming your way soon
you